Welcome ! Are you ready to fight some
Beastss?!?!?(I sure as hell am!)
In beast marrr...Beast master simulator.
Okay. I have no idea what this game is- I assume
it's sort of like the other one we played. Remember that one? - of course you do you, you watch all my videos!
Goddamn right you do! All right where should we go... Soccer?
*It's Soccer Actually!*
Let's save these for later. Okay? Let's start with good old grasslands.
Okay, alright. So what do we got?
This is it ?
Oh, okay.
This is the grasslands.
Very exciting, not so exciting, okay we can spawn...
We can spawn all kinds of shit(satan?). Oh my God...
Let's start...
with Seagull!(cuz why the HELL NOT)
*poof*
Pff hahaha!
*long gasp*
Okay, we got a sea- how about two seagulls? *poof* There you go...
Versus, of course...
A tank.(yeah that is totally a fair battle)
Who would win??(seagull ofc)
*Tank fires*
*seagulls crying, bones crushing*
PFFF-AHAHAHA (welp i was wrong.)
HEUP
HAHAHAHAHA--
*gasp* HEE-HEE--YE-EAH! (EPIC laugh)
Tha- the tank wins everybody! Surprise!(noo (ಥ﹏ಥ))
Surprise everybody! The tank wins! *giggling*
What if we add... A Zebra to the mix? Huh?(hmm that would turn the tides)
H-How- how *poof* would that affect things?
Come on, Zebra!
*bones crushing, splattering noises*
*voice sample from Call of Duty* "Mission failed. We'll get 'em next time"
Oh, I'm gonna look away from tha- okay the tank... The tank wins.(TANK IS TOO OP)
How about...
We're- we're gonna, uh, T-rex.
We're gonna add a- wait what the fuck is this?
*It's A Brontosaurus Pewds, god, know your dinosaurs*
Okay.
Okay. This is interesting. This is interesting.(VERY.)
Come on! COME ON YOU SON OF A BITCH! FIGHT HIM LIKE A MAN!(*Brontosaurus)
Oh shit, tank misses!(HOW can it MISS a DINOSAUR?)
He doesn't really know how to attack, it-it seems like-
OH-fff-shit!
His... His leg got blown off. His... leg got blown up, and then they need -Tank is strong!
*Great Grammar*
Humans are strong!
Come on dino. You gotta win this one! What about a raptor, huh?
What about- couple raptors...
Come on Raptors! Come on Raptors, eat that tank-(wait.. can raptors eat tanks??)
Aw, the raptors gettin' mauled...(SOMEONE NERF TANK!!)
They get MAULED, I say!
Okay. Well clearly... Clearly this is not gonna work
We're gonna need, I wanna, T-rex, right? A T-rex...
A buncha T-rex-- a bunch a' ffffreakin' T-rex!
Here we go- Come on, T-Rex!
*explosions, dinosaur rawrs*
Get that tank!(YEAH!)
Man- tank its strong, man!(OP Right.)
YES!!(Pewds satisfied)
Good job, Dino! Good jooob!
You work together as a team, and you can do anything.
This is amazing! This game is... Incredible!(Totally!)
Alright, let's, uh, keep it back, uh, simple.
A Kangaroo,
right?
Versus...
Seagull.
I felt like seagulls, uh, they're pretty good.(You are right Pewds I think so too)
Whoa!! jumped over Seagull!(MATRIX!)
*crunch* OH!
Who won? I can't even tell...
They're still fighting, I believe.
Seagull won? No, no seagull lost. Okay.(NOOOOOOOO ಠ_ಥ)
How many seagulls, does it take to one- kill one Kangaroo? Oh?
*crunch* *crunch* *crunch
Oh, my, Lord.(BRUTAL MURDER)
Well, good job, Seagull wins.(Guess Seagulls are now OP too)
How many seagulls does it take to kill one T-Rex?(Hmmm..)
*Epic music starts*
Oh my God, they're STRONG! Yeah, go forth, my-- Oh my God, he's spinning out!(Yessss)
Go seagulls! Get him! Get him, seagulls!(Yeah seagulls Finish Him)
GET 'EM SEASGULLS!!!(ლ(´ڡ`ლ))
Come on, seagulls!! Come on, you can get 'em!
FIGHT!
Fight, goddammit, seagulls!
SEAGULLS(SEAGULLS!)
Come on! There's two left! come on, seagulls!
It's close! It's close!!
SEAGULLLLLLLLLLLLS!!!!!!!(YEAAAA!! ლ,ᔑ•ﺪ͟͠•ᔐ.ლ)
*unintelligible celebration*
The Seagulls are strong, goddammit...(Too OP ᕦ(Ò_Óˇ)ᕤ)
Holy shiiiiiiih!
Seagulls, man!
What about Seagulls, versus a minigun, Huh?(Interesting.)
*minigun firing, seagull cries*
*crash* *crash* *crash*
"Seagulls are freakin' amazing!!"(You said it Pewds!)
What about against a barrel, huh?
*mumbling* well, thsda point...
How about a spinosaurus? What that hell is-- Oh, okay.
*more crying, and crunching*
Who knew! Seagulls!
Seagulls were the greatest animal alive!(I know RIGHT!)
Oh my g-- ahahaha!
*Pewds wheeze* *Pewds wheeze*
This game is ridiculous...
*seriously, the crunching is unsettling*
I've never been more proud of you, seagulls!
I'm not sure how they are fighting... To be honest...(I guess by Pecking??)
Look at him! They're ruthless animals!(Totally)
Roofless*
Wait, they actually play football?
Okay, dog... Right?
Team dog,
Versus...
Team...
Elephant. Who would win? A bunch of dogs versus an elephant.
Come on, little do- aw, sausage dogs as well
Oh- okay, well- pfft-ohmygod-ahahahaha!(Noooo THOSE DOGS ಥ_ಥ)
*massive dog massacre*
*Maniacal laughter, spastic gasping and wheezing*
Ahhh! Aww nooo!
Oh noooo!
Oh! oh wowwwww, okay.
Arright well that... That answers that question.
Poor-- Okay, all right well okay, okay, Alright, alright, alright, Let's clear up the dogs, cuz that was horrible...(yes)
What about my famous seagulls, huh? What about my favorite- favorite- famous seagulls?(OP AF)
There we go! Okay!
Come on s- whoa!
Seagulls are strong! Come on Seag--
*Laugh* They just throw themselves after the ball! Come on seagulls! Play as a team! Play as a team!
SEAGULLLLLLLLLS!!!!!!(YESSS ᕙ(⇀‸↼‶)ᕗ)
SEAGULLS! SEAGULLS! SEAGULLS!(SEAGULLS FTW!)
Look at 'em go!(Such Majestic Creatures)
Alright, what a banch-- a bunch of raptors...
They're pretty fast, right?
Come on. Seagulls...
Come on, Seagulls...!
Damn, they're killing it! They can take concoll--- They can take control!
Raptor stand no chance! SEAGULLS!(Honestly the game made seagulls OP)
THE STRONGEST ANIMAL ALIVE!!(Pewds is right ya know)
Goddamn, if pokemon were real, you know I would pick the Seagulls!(Me TOO)
You know it!
What about the Brach...(??)
Triceratops, huh?(Got it right now..)
What a buncha buncha-- look how many-
Okay I'm gonna give you so many goddamn Triceratops,
There's no way you can lose this, Triceratops!
You're a stupid animal as well! I hated you in that cartoon with the annoying girl character!
Oh my lord.
Come on Seagulls, there's not many of you left!
Come on Seagulls-- YOU MISSED!!(NOOOOOOOOO ┬──┬ ノ( ゜-゜ノ))
SS--AGHHHH!!(I CRI ༼ つ ಥ_ಥ ༽つ)
NOOO!
NOOOOOOOOO!
SEAGULLS!!
We're gonna-- We're gonna try that again.(REMATCH!)
We're gonna try that again. Come on Seagulls! Come on, SEAGULLS!(COME ON!)
Use your team work! Tactics! Skills-- *CRASHCRUSHSPLAT*
Oh no... Oh, ohhhh, ahhh, auuhhh...(*CENSORED*)
Oh, I don't know what just happened, but I don't think it was pretty...(Yeah I agree)
There's still one brave seagull fighting off-- *ferocious crushing noises*
Ehehe, It's fighting against... Five triceratops!(I CALL HAX)
Come on, Seagull-- *THUNDERING EXPLOSION*(Did the seagull self destruct?/)
Oh wow. Oh. Oh. Oh.(Still OP)
This is the greatest game.
Of all time
The Coliseum. Yes!(Colosseum*)
The ancient Romans used to battle!(You got that right)
OH! PTERODACTYLS!(*excited Pewds)
YES!(YESS)
*high pitch voice* Pterra-pterr!(Totally accurate impression)
Go! Go! Yeah!(GOO)
Awee, YES!
More!(( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°))
Get that tank -- Aw, he lost his leg, that's fine!(They dont need legs anyways)
He didn't need legs, he's a bird!!
My God, yes!
Did he win?!
They won!! Oh my god-- Pterodactyl has to be my favorite animal... My favorite dinosaur!
This got really interesting- because how many pterodactyls will they take to kill a seagull?(Y DO U DO THIS PEWDS ༼ つ ಥ_ಥ ༽つ)
Right?
Surely, these Seagulls should have no chance...
Oh my God! Oh my God, you got messed up!(Well Seagulls=OP)
You got messed up right away, dude.
Seagulls don't mess around. Seagulls don't mess around.(They either die or kill)
I bet you three Seagulls can kill this Pterodactyl.(lets see.)
*intense fighting with epic music*
One died.(noooo)
*more intense fighting, still epic music*
LOOK!
Aww nooo.(NOOOOO ಥ_ಥ)
Noooo!
Peter...(Y PETER ಥ_ಥ)
Aw, Peter, I'm so disappointed...
FINALLY we get the
scientific answers of all these
Questions that we've asked ourselves for a very very very long time- at least I have.(I did ask myself these too)
I don't know I think about these things
Okay, so...
We-- I didn't know you could put stuff on people, so
Seagull, right? Seagull. Right?
Gear,
Laser...(Oh yess)
Ehhhhh...
You can't? You can't put a laser on 'em?(Noo) How 'bout a bomb.(Self destruct)
Okay, all right. How about this:
We put it on the other side, huh?
Rhino with guns.
Laser fricken Seagulls!?(YEAAA ヾ(⌐■_■)ノ♪)
Kay, they all have lasers...(NOW theyre more OP)
Okay, okay, okayokayokay,
This's gonna be awesome. x4(I BET 5 bucks on seagulls)
Okay, so...
Right, T-rex... Right, T-Rex
Arright
Three, freakin, T-rex. And then, to make it more fair, we give them one...
dog(totally fair.)
*blindingly loud epic music*
Oh no... Oh no... Oh dog I got bad news for you, dog...(noo (;´༎ຶД༎ຶ`))
Dog, you should-- no dog, don't do it... Don't do it, dog
Don't do it. Don't do it, dog
Dog, dog, you're really brave, brave is--((;´༎ຶД༎ຶ`))
Oh no... Ohhh no...(ಥ_ಥ)
Oh-- Oh-- Ohh noooo...(ಥ_ಥ)
Poor little doggy(ಥ_ಥ)
Awwww- Nnn whatcha sayyyyy~
Mmmm datchu only meant wellll~(epic singing skillz)
well a' course you did~
Mmmm watchu sayyyyy~
*high notes* Mm that's it's all for the best~~~([̲̅$̲̅(̲̅5̲̅)̲̅$̲̅] well here is my 5 bucks)
Well this has been beast battle simulator. Thank you for leaving a like on this video!
Fam squad jujitsu! *poof*
portalSFX.mp3